[Music]
so
today i have the good fortune
of speaking with mr matthew mcconaughey
who's
one of america's most recognizable
actors and
i guess according to his peers also one
of america's best actors
as he's won an academy award and
multiple other rewa
awards and we
started to communicate about a year ago
and
he's also been on my daughter's podcast
and matthew recently wrote a book
green lights which we're going to talk
about today i've
read that and and uh
i'm looking forward to discussing it
there's all sorts of things i want to
talk to
matthew about and so
hopefully we'll have a stimulating
conversation that's my guess
so let's start with well we can start
with whatever you want to start
with but let's start with the book i
think
tell me why you wrote it and and when
you wrote it and
what you want people to know about it
yes so
i've been keeping journals since i was
14 years old
um and so
i guess starting 15 years ago i always
carry this treasure chest full of the
journals i'd been keeping
and they were filling up that treasure
chest and i would take it with me to any
place that we went for an extended
amount of time
put it over there to the right of my
proverbial desk and go
have it there because if you get the
itch and you get some time
i dare you to go on that treasure chest
and see what's in there
well i've threatened to open up that
treasure chest and see what those
journals held for the past 15 years
didn't have the courage really to uh to
open it up didn't didn't want to make
the time
to go in there because i was intimidated
of looking back at 50 years or
however many years of my life i'm not
one
for really liking to look back over my
shoulder i'm somebody who likes to you
know i'm still someone who rather
enjoys making the sandwich more than
eating it i like making my movies more
than i even like watching them i like
doing things moving on
and uh and heading forward so well you
must have had some idea too when you
were making those journals at least in
principle that
you owed an obligation to yourself at
some point to look back over them and
i can see that that would be
intimidating because you're creating a
a task for yourself a task of
reconsideration and contemplation
i suppose well my my excuse
was oh when i die
camilo open them up and if there's
something worth sharing she'll do it
which wasn't used um in martyrdom you
know if there's something worth it
so i uh maybe it was coming across 50
unconsciously i didn't think about 50 as
a number of the time to be
retrospective but i had some time on my
hands
and i had read an article in the new
york times that a young man had written
and i liked
the article oh this guy gets me in a way
that it was first article i read where
he had weaved all different times of my
my career and life
into a thread instead of sort of like
saying he was this then
and now he's this and this then and now
he's this so he'd strung them all
together and i liked his style of
writing
and i asked him to come on and be a
ghostwriter for a book
we met one time it was a good meeting
we thought it was going to be a book a
little hardback book that you could put
on the back of the toilet that every
college kid could take to
school and could open it up any page
maybe read a
truthism tourism or a bumper sticker or
something and have a little aspiration
ahead about their day
well the new york times pulled him off
because evidently they weren't allowing
the writers to work with celebrities and
just as
he got pulled off and i was in the in
the room my office with camilla my wife
i said i think i need to find a new
ghost rep
and i stopped at the same time she
stopped and
she said you know what this means i went
yeah i do know what it means
which is i need to go off and ride it
myself so she said
i packed up the uh all the journals she
said uh don't come back until you got
something
and i headed off with uh 15 gallons of
water
i don't know how many pounds of red meat
and
and and my favorite my favorite libation
and i went away to the desert
uh the first 12 days were sort of no
electricity me with my journals
uh no no cell reception nothing like
that i wanted to be forced with nothing
but my past
um and find some entertainment in that
at least
and i uh feared being embarrassed i
feared being
feeling ashamed and i feared seeing a
arrogant little sob that i was in the
past and i crossed all those things
and looking back at my last 50 years um
but what i noticed was that the things
that a lot of things i thought i'd be
embarrassed about
i giggled at a lot of thought to be
ashamed about
i had already forgiven myself for or not
forgave myself for
and a lot of the times where i was an
arrogant little sob what i realized
is that if i wasn't the arrogant little
sob at that time i may not have had the
confidence to put myself in a situation
to get absolutely humiliated and humbled
so i sat down with uh
the uh the journals i remember thinking
going into thinking it was going to be
more academic
thinking that that's what it was that's
what it was
after day five i realized no
there's actually more folk poetry in
here and stories to tell
than any academia so i backed off and
said let's just see what the journals
give reveal themselves to be and i ended
up with eight stacks
of all the journals i said what are some
themes had a big stack of stories big
stack of people
big stack of places big stack of
pre-scribes big stack of poems
prayers and bumper stickers so i had
these eight stacks i said okay
now let's sift through those and see if
we find a central theme
and that's where green lights came from
i found that i had
engineered green lights in my life
through responsibilities taken yesterday
which bore me freedom today i found that
i'd gotten just plumb
i have no reason why good fortune landed
in my lap
uh there was no reason why but i said
well let's make some rhyme out of this
and do something with it
i found that also a lot of my yellow and
red lights
those things that we don't really like
that slow us down or make us stop
all had lessons that they revealed to me
which then
enhanced made them green lights or at
least
gave them green light assets um
and then i also found that um that the
art
has sort of been approaching me online
all right so
we've reestablished ourselves in a
win-free zone
so look one of the things you struck me
as an intensely likable character
as a consequence of what you revealed in
your book i mean i
i kept thinking um it would be a
pleasure to spend time around this
man and i certainly saw no sign of
arrogance in it
um i thought i saw a lot of thankfulness
and conscious thankfulness and i think
implicit thankfulness as well
and um a lot of a lot of love
for your family your parents and and
your current family
uh and gratitude for that as well and
also one of the things that struck me
too was your
um integrity and decision making with
regards to your career you
you talked about taking a break after
being somewhat typecast in romantic
comedies i mean very successfully
typecast and so there's nothing
negative about that but feeling that
you had taken that as far as it could be
taken
yes productively and creatively and and
then took a risk of
really being bounced out of the system i
mean one of the things i think that
people
perhaps don't understand about
a society or a situation as intensely
competitive as hollywood is that
it's virtually impossible to be
successful there and the probability
that you'll fail even if you are
successful is extremely high
because the competition is
beyond belief there's no help wanted
signs
no definitely not and so if you decide
to do something like
think well i've been successful in
romantic comedies but i don't want that
anymore
you're throwing away something that's
virtually impossible to attain and then
to imagine that you might recreate
yourself in the different
guys and be successful it's a it's a big
risk you see this often when actors fail
to make the transition from television
to
to the big screen and that that happens
far more often than it doesn't happen
even if they have a very successful
tv career so all of that was extremely
interesting
um now okay so you were out in the
desert writing your book how long did it
take you to sort through
the material i went off into solitude
five different times for 10 to 12 days a
piece
the first trip out was to the desert for
the first 12 days
and that was basically to see what i had
um
i came back from that
feeling like i had something that was
that was personal that might be worthy
of being
on between you know two hardback covers
um i remember writing early on going
okay
now you're gonna have a lot of people
that are gonna buy this book even if
it's
the words are crap on the page because
of who you are mcconaughey i said you're
gonna have a lot of people who are not
gonna
purchase this book even if what you put
on the page was awesome because you're
math mechanics i remember saying
to myself and one of the first things i
wrote down i was like the words on the
page need to be worthy of being put on
the page if they were signed by
anonymous
but at the same time need to be words
that only
mathematically could have written and
that was sort of my little bubble
going because this is not about you've
read it's not about a celebrity book
um no in fact there's very little in it
that's
celebrity like i was actually struck by
how infrequently you made reference to
your
to you to the milieu that that that you
inhabited while you were
well while you've been pursuing your
career as an actor there's there's no
celebrity gossip in it
it's very it's it's it's family-centered
and very intimate
um i actually i actually
wanted it left me wanting to know more
about your career and so we can also
talk about that today
flesh that out but so that was quite
remarkable for
you know a celebrity memoir let's say
it's a terrible way of phrasing it
a memoir by someone who happens to be a
celebrity yeah yeah
yeah well it wasn't a celebrity memoir
it was a it was a
an autobiographical meditation i would
say
okay heard i like that so i went away i
went away i came back the first 12 days
i was like okay i think i got something
and then i'd come back handle my
honeydews at home get everything back
make sure i didn't fall too much in the
deficit of being a father and a husband
back home
and then as soon as i could head off
again
um i was fortunate to have a wife who
was like get out of here each time
you know when i came you could tell how
you know the first
the first 12 days were like a purge i
mean i came back and
and the whole family like saw me i mean
i came back
shedding tears i had just sort of
gone back and looked at 50 years of my
life and had them down and all of a
sudden was crying they were tears of joy
of this love story that i was
seeing and to face certain things that i
looked at in the past or forgot in the
past or
thought i forgot but noticed that
actually i'd remembered um
was aw it was a very earth shaking my
floor was moved in a good way
yeah well that's great that it was moved
in a good way you know i mean
that's a lovely thing to have happen to
you when you're 50 and looking back
yes and then four other trips uh so 52
total days
i was in solitude and then the next year
and a half was
basically editing it
and you know i didn't have as many of
the stories in there early
which i would say serve as sort of the
narrative backbone
throughout that string the whole piece
together yeah enter
intermittently in there i'll put a poem
a prescribe
a prayer or something that either call
back i looked at them in like in movies
like their flashback or a flash forward
and can they coming out of a story tell
the reader
oh this is how i saw the situation that
you just read
or can it propel you into the next story
because the story the stories are really
more chronological
um that take you from four years old to
50.
um and i didn't have as many of the
stories in there um and so the next year
and a half was going okay
i've got these stories my my editors i
would tell them she was like oh geez you
got to put that in there
and that's when it became again i was i
was hesitant about the word memoir i
don't have a great relationship with the
word memoir
memoir it seems like good night
everybody
i'm heading off into the twilight of my
career the sun setting
have a look and i was like because i
need these stories to be
active because they are still active and
so
right telling them as long as they had a
vitality that they felt active which
they felt like they were
and then i had that that uh that thing
that is so obvious
when you say it but it didn't feel
obvious to me at the time
which was the more personal i got the
more i started to notice
that it was probably more relatable the
more into the eye that i went this
objective the more i
noticed that oh it's actually more
relatable to more of the human condition
and that was my hope um and uh yeah well
you have a there's a there's a
it's a it's a great it's a collection of
great stories
and part of the good fortune of your
life is to have had those
experiences that transform themselves
into
compelling stories without
what would you say without undue editing
the african story for example the dream
story that's quite that was quite
remarkable
for me that was a highlight of the book
i would say
where you related the dream you had a
recurring dream or at least one that
recurred twice and
um and on the basis of that dream voyage
to south america and to africa is that i
hope i've got that right
the second time i had the dream which
was the exact
same dream 11 frames 11 seconds the
second time i had it is when i chased
down the first half of the dream which
was south america i thought i'd finish
it
then five years after that i had the
dream for the third time which made me
say oh i gotta chase down the second
half which was their african tribesmen
on the
banks of the river to the left and
that's when i went to africa any idea
why
i mean you staked a lot on the pursuit
of a dream
and i mean maybe we could say that's the
motif of your book that you staked a lot
on the pursuit of a dream but
it's much more concrete in that episode
you had an
actual dream a literal nighttime dream
that recurred
and as a consequence of that you you
took a large
risk or a series of risks merely going
to africa was a risk
i would say and not something that would
be expected it's quite out of the
ordinary to do that
obviously well i've never had i've had
dreams that are similar
to each other but i've nev it's the only
dream i've ever had that
one was so specifically i mean it was
exact when i say 11 frames i mean like
film frames picture
one two three
for 11 seconds the exact same frames
exact same editing sequence in my mind
11 seconds that
ended in such a i don't know if ironic's
the right way word
ended it was the elements of a nightmare
but it was the opposite of a nightmare
it was a wet dream
and so the fact that it was the exact
same dream that i've had
once in 92 again in 96 whoa i had that
twice that's the first shake up well
that was the exact same dream i had four
years ago
exactly first time that's ever happened
oh that's
maybe that's a celestial suggestion here
somebody something
is telling me what do you think you
specifically learned in pursuit of that
and have you had the dream again my
guess would be no that you probably
exhausted it but i might be wrong
no i have not to this to this point
is it seems that i fulfilled it the
dream
in the trip to africa which was the two
elements of the dream
one was the amazon river one were
african trash those are the two
geographic elements that i knew
that were crystal clear in the dream um
so that's why i went to south america
that's why i went live i have not had it
again
um i mean
one i one i'll say this
i'm always looking for a good reason to
go for a walkabout
yeah another really good reason a
concrete
reason there and why were they wet
dreams there was nothing
overtly sexual about them there was i
don't you know um so
they were you know spiritual in that way
is how i took them
now in mali i can say and i've been back
to mali i went back to mali
as i write about in the book five years
later after i fulfilled the dream
not because i had the dream again just
because molly
i've never felt more at home in a place
than molly now you're in certain places
like i've been here before
this is my big gravity here is right
i've been here before whether it's
another life i don't know
but mali was where i felt
business home this was the original home
i've been here um and so that's what
went back so that's my favorite place to
go and i've been back and did the exact
same trip i did
when i chased down the second half of
the dream and you shed
you shed your identity to a great degree
when you went to africa
and so that may enable you to
exist in a way that would be much unlike
the manner in which you have to exist
where people know where you are
or who you are um what do you think that
did for you
like the dream you you took this dream
quest
let's say and and you paid a price for
it
the risk would be the price
what was the consequence of allowing
yourself to do that
um that it was one that was on me
that it was my doing i could own it
at a time of becoming famous you go
through at least i
did and still do at times go through
wait a minute what's mine
what am i getting based off of my worth
as the man i
am as the person i am forget my thing
and it becomes challenging
you know what is it real what is it not
how many of those i love you's or meant
or how many of them would just follow
him because i just had a big box office
hit
and wait a minute the person that have
had dinner with their kids and spent
christmases with
who have shared i love using hugs then
now i have two movies that didn't do
well and that person won't return my
call wait a minute
what all matters what do i want to do
what are we what are we doing here so
if you have a rep if you have a
reputation
that has a life of its own it becomes
very difficult to distinguish between
yourself and that reputation
and that's one of the pitfalls of fame
and lots of times you see people
sacrifice themselves
to their reputation you see celebrities
becoming impersonators of themselves
yes and that's a it's a tragic fate i
would say
and and well that's when you go i've
that's yeah who's wagging who
i've never wanted pain to wag me i mean
like no no i got
i understand i got famous because of who
to whatever extent because of who
i am and what what did i do yeah well i
could see in the book that you were
snapping yourself out of your fame
even while you were doing things like
the motorhome adventures because
you were living a life that certainly
wouldn't it was certainly wasn't what i
expected to read
that you would voluntarily
abandon what so many people
value as like the pinnacle of
of cultural achievement say at the
popular level
and shed all that and and set out like
any any
any person who who doesn't have that
right
well what i was like for instance in the
south american trip
and it happened in the molly trips and
all the walk the walkabouts it was
i needed to go to a place where nobody i
had just become famous to i mean my
world was like all of a sudden all the
options were mine
and two days before there were none of
those options were there
and now it was a world of yes and i'm
going i only have 24 hours in a day and
i would do any of this work and you're
now telling me i can do it all
yeah i mean you're asking me to be
discerning right now
and again i went away to go i need to go
where someone doesn't know my name
i need to go away where
no one's seen my movies i want to go
where there's no electricity i want to
go someplace where those hugs and tears
when i say goodbye 22 days later
are based only off of the man they met
22 days ago
well you you managed to abandon them too
one of the problems with being famous is
and i suspect this is particularly the
case with the kind of fame that you have
is that it must be very difficult to
distinguish between
people wanting something from you and
people enjoying your company and liking
you
and it might even be difficult for them
to distinguish between those things
because
fame is a very difficult thing to deal
with even as an
onlooker even as a family member you
wrote about your mom's reaction for
example
she became a fan girl to some degree
and that that would be definitely
disconcerting
yes it was yeah i had eight years there
where my mom and i
i i couldn't i needed a mother and what
i
on the other hand the phone was a fan
of my fame somebody who wanted my fame
more than i did
great well it shows you the power of
that too because your mother obviously
cared for the person you were
before you became famous but she was
overwhelmed
and it's not surprising i mean to some
degree the entire hollywood apparatus
exists to manufacture fame that's
overwhelming
that's its whole i can't say that's its
whole purpose but that's what it uses to
drive let's say to to drive people to
the theater
so to be victimized by that no no to
to fall under the sway of that is
unsurprising it's surprising that
it could be resisted and and that was
certainly
you could certainly see that with your
mother's response oh for sure
and that has that i'm sorry i don't
remember your mom
is your mom still alive yes she is she's
88 and 88 years young and with us right
now
uh uh so and has that has that situation
rectified itself did she adapt to
we both adapted yeah um you know i
i got through enough time where i felt
stable enough in my career
that i was like her loose lips
aren't going to sink my [ __ ] and
actually i like the reigns and as soon
as i said
you go mom here's the mic hit that red
carpet line you can talk to anybody you
tell
no filter sell whatever stories you want
99 of time it's awesome and
i'm like you know what let her enjoy it
and i was able to
enjoy it and then come to that you know
the realization that
you know i wasn't going to change her so
because i couldn't change her
it's kind of like the sabbatical i took
from the rom-coms i wasn't going to
change her so i just had to kind of
block her out for a certain amount of
time that ended up being eight years
until i was stable enough to go go for
it
and uh yeah our relationship's great you
know all through that time
she didn't love me less she's loved me
in a new different way
as well as being her son what i was
needing was just i needed her to double
down on being a mom
to me where instead of she didn't double
down she didn't even cut it in half she
kind of
was really wanting to know about the
fame part i remember telling her things
like
boy you keep wanting to come out here
and see me but what if i was an
accountant in chicago would you want to
come see me as much
and my two brothers were like you don't
want to come see us as much you want to
see little brother and we were like
yeah we get it you know so we call her
out and
um yeah it was a strange eight years i
never
questioned her love for me though i knew
we were gonna be fine i knew we weren't
gonna like
head to our death beds going on on a bad
note
i knew we were gonna come out the other
side it's just a matter of when and we
did
yeah well it's it's nonetheless a good
example of one of the unintended
consequences of fame right is that
the this this very profound alteration
in the nature of your personal
relationships
so yes so um
i want to switch topics a bit i've been
watching you in um
true detective which
my son recommended and i'm really
enjoying
you i believe you said in the book that
the script leapt off the page for you
it did especially the words of the
character rustin cole
right right who you play marty heart
roll that woody played
yes you were offered that rule yes
yeah and i read the thing and i remember
telling them i said
guys i understand why you're coming to
me for marty hart i go but the guy who i
cannot wait to turn the page to see what
comes out of his mouth
is this guy rusting coal and they were a
bit surprised
yeah well they're both complex
characters so you could see that either
of them might have been attractive
but i was i i'm i was quite struck by
your your characterization of
of coal um it reminded me of heath
ledger
and that's why i wanted to talk to you
about it
you you play a dark character very well
if you don't mind me saying so
i mean thank you um
it's believable i've known some dark
people
and your portrayal is believable very
believable and so
that makes me wonder what price you pay
for that's kind of a cliche you know you
play a dark role and it invades you but
it isn't obvious to me how you can play
a dark role without it invading you and
then
or at least you have to allow something
dark in yourself to come out and respond
to that and
you're very different on the screen
playing rust and cold than you are in
a romantic comedy role clearly
and it's it's somewhat surprising to see
that transition
which i guess is why other people might
be surprised by that too which is why
you actually had a bit of a hiatus when
you stopped taking rom-com rules
but i'm curious like what did it what
were the consequences for you of playing
that character in particular but dark
characters in general
the dark the dark characters the the
baddie
usually has so much more identity
than the white knight than the hero in
stories that i read in scripts and
things
um the dark characters
and also they're they're always usually
outsiders
and i the consequences that i'm really
gonna
portray one of those well that part of
myself i'm putting myself on an island
and i love and i'm and that excites me
i want it to be i want to feel like the
underdog i want to feel like i don't
have to pander to manners or graces i'm
living by different rules
and not even to prove a point but just
saying a russian cole's position
someone who just you know i didn't
make big acting choices with russian co
i just
did what i could to understand the text
so well
that i could just say it and not have to
solicit it or
again rusted rusting coal was a guy who
preferred his own company to anyone
else's and
and and that solitude that was a
vacation for me also to
as a person who was a believer to have
to to
to be in a in an inhabited character who
is not a believer at all and here's why
um
[Music]
i'll tell you i've always thought this
was odd
at the time that i chose and wanted to
go and have it rust and cold
was the time that my faith was strongest
and if my faith would have been as
strong
i might have been a little more fearful
of going so deep into
this man's mind spirit and ethos
and so you had some protection
but very nihilistic the character call
he reminds me there's a philosopher in
south africa who's an
anti-natalist um unfortunately
his name escapes me for a moment i i had
a debate with him a couple of years ago
but
his basic premise is that
conscious suffering is so morally
untenable as a phenomenon that all life
should cease that if we were making the
proper moral choices we'd stop
reproducing but not only that that we'd
we'd also
do what we could well we can leave it at
that that we'd stop reproducing because
if you sum up a life it's it's bitter
and
and the bitterness overwhelms the sweet
and so it's cruelty to perpetuate
yes i i think that is is beautiful and
in many ways true and i think it's also
hilarious
um
what strikes you is as comical about
that you you laughed about it and
because that's where of course
of course we're on the way to dying you
talk about it all the time it's tough
it's cruel it's hard we're out here this
thing is
okay i'm in so that's inevitable that's
the strange thing you know and i i felt
too
i mean i can certainly understand the
argument
i i hear it and i and it adds up
but if that's inevitable
which i think we all say that's
inevitable it's typed we're on the way
to dying it's over what's that we don't
we'll never know
if this is the end or not so hell you
know or
or if there's anything after it and it
is it's hardships and overcome
okay since that's inevitable and we got
to do this thing anyway
if we're choosing to stay in life
another day
so what's a better way to go about it
saying it's all for nothing or realizing
right there when you go it's all for
nothing no that's why [ __ ] it's all
for everything
yeah well there is it also seems to me
that
if your objection to life is its
suffering
adopting an attitude that will make that
suffering worse
is probably not a reasonable solution
and that that's that's where that
grounds out for me there's no
construction in there
what i mean there's nothing there's
nothing affirmative or life giving about
that's not making the best of the
situation
if the situation's doomed day so you
know i'm not for hallmark cards and
delusional optimism but i mean and in
this way i would say optimism is
survival
it's like well okay if it's all for i
think optimism is
courage if it's not naive and one of the
things i liked about your book too was
that your optimism
wasn't naive and
you know because you had enough harsh
experiences
so that any naive optimism would have
vanished
right even your even your the way you
grew up
i mean it wasn't traumatic but it wasn't
it wasn't uh
it had its harshness about it sure yeah
it was it was immediate
it was physical the same hands that
hugged the same hands that could harm
yes and you all there was also very
little sign of and maybe none
no sign of bitterness about that and and
no sign
i didn't think of any excuses for it
either like
when you portrayed your father like you
said
he was a man who could hug and hit and
both of them were meant
and they weren't casual i i never got
the impression from from your book
that your father's actions were casual
his physical altercations with you and
and your brothers um it was a different
it's a different ethos
that's not an ethos that's well
understood today i would say or one
that's that's ever appreciated and
i suppose that's because of its
harshness but
i didn't detect any sign of bitterness
from you emanating towards that
no and and i have i have none um
while i choose to
maybe give consequences to my children
in different ways than my father
and mother did um
there was absolutely no casualness to
why and when
he did punish us none i talk about in
there
what you know the values that were
instilled even by the antonyms of the
words that we got in trouble for saying
do not to to get their first butt
whooping for saying i can't
oh geez okay i mean you know
can't brings the thought of can't brings
pain oh don't think can't
okay you have trouble there's a
difference
and to say the second open for saying i
hate you to my brother i didn't know the
hell i hate you man i heard it from
older
kids at school and i thought it might be
cool to throw it out there i hate you
well that was my own birthday party my
mom stopped the whole party
and said what'd you say you don't ever
tell
your brother anyone you hate them bent
me over right there embarrass the heck
out of me
again the next one for lying so
what do i learn out of those don't
say i can't don't hate don't lie
boy when i did those i felt pain so
what are the antonyms of those um
but instead of hate i understand you're
having trouble but don't believe you
can't
and tell the truth don't lie those are
three great values he was preparing me
or you're going to need this in in life
you know it was also the time when i
called when i called him to go
to tell i want to go to film school and
said law school and he tells me yeah
that was a striking story you know what
happened i've realized now
many years later i think what happened
in that moment
is he heard and the conversation lasted
25 seconds
ah what do you got little buddy don't
want to go to law school i want to go to
film school you sure that's what you
want to do
yes sir
well don't half-ass it boom sent me the
flag
but what he heard in that conversation
was his son who we were brought up in a
very structured
family discipline you worked your way up
a ladder you follow the rules
he heard his son calling him to tell him
he could tell i was asked calling for
permission
you could tell i wasn't calling kind of
well you know i was thinking maybe
no he heard my voice i want to go to
film school instead of law school
and he said you also weren't calling
because of failure because you'd worked
at law school
right but he heard that i was not
bluffing i was not
really calling to ask his permission and
in that moment i think he heard
what all parents want to hear yes
my child's going their own way they
broke out the mold
yeah well what you'd hope every parent
would want to hear
i hope so but you know what i mean you
can't come i i had plenty of times
before that that i asked him for things
where i was bluffing
and he could tell where dad can i will
you please give me the skateboard elbow
pads and knee pads i really want to be a
skateboarder are you sure your son
yes sir [ __ ] i did skateboarding for
three weeks and then they gathered dust
and got cobwebs
damn it that was a fad you know i talked
my dad into doing something and i didn't
follow through on it
but he heard this time
no resolve and clarity in me and i think
on the other line he was going
that's my boy yeah well for him to make
the
to give you the green light that rapidly
the situation must have been set up
properly
and for the green light that he gave you
to be accepted by you is exactly that as
encouragement
yes the situation must have been set up
properly okay so you talked about
playing
coal in in true detective and that you
were protected from his dark excesses
let's say by your faith
why did that provide you with in what
way did that provide you with protection
it's a striking thing to say especially
given his
his attitude is is mephistopheleian
there's a character in gertha's
faust mephistopheles who's satan himself
and his
essential credo is that everything that
lives should perish because of the
the sin of its existence essentially and
so
that's coal in a nutshell right
yeah and and and
and that's it it is a it is it's a
logically tenable argument but it's one
that needs to be rejected
holistically i i shouldn't use that word
i hate that word but
you don't reject that argument
rationally because it's a rationally
tenable argument you have to reject it
with your whole being instead and say
well despite this i'm going to live
and i'm going to try to live in an
appropriate manner
yes but you said your faith protected
you from coal
well it was one of the things that that
allowed me to
fully go into coal and fully believe
coal and get down and
live it and and look at the world
through that lens
right i had already had year a few years
running my life where i was quite
agnostic
it was my agnosticism was not about
trying to prove the disbelief of god's
existence my agnosticism was about
me going you sure have been letting
yourself off the hook mcconnell hey
mr fatalisto i'll forgive you again
because you're being a repeat offender
and i'm kind of tired of it put your
damn hands on the wheel man
talking to myself um you're driving here
and quit going to this i can pray and be
forgiven
but you're repeat offending cut it out i
had gone through
a few years earlier in my life of of
agnosticism where i was not so much
trying to
prove a non-existence of god as i was
trying to have more
understand more self-reliance and
self-determination on myself because
i've been letting myself off the hook
and and how how was that related to the
agnosticism
do you think because you you put those
together in
in the way that you're relating this
story
well i needed to have i needed to
i knew i needed to feel like i
was wholly responsible
for myself and what happened to me
that that i was uh um
uh not gonna let myself slide
there's an ideal calling to you then
like when you experience
yourself as ashamed by your own
behaviors
what that means is that there's an ideal
inside you that's trying to manifest
itself right because you wouldn't
be ashamed if you weren't comparing
yourself to something better
and the question then becomes well what
is that
better thing that you're comparing
yourself to and it's an ideal
and then the question becomes well what
is the ideal you know and that's the
sort of
fleshing out what that ideal is is that
that's the function of religious
thinking and so that's why i was
interested in your comment about
agnosticism
you know um in in revelation in the book
of revelation christ comes back as a
judge
even though he's a figure of mercy let's
say he comes back as a judge and the
reason for that
this is from carl jung the reason for
that is that any ideal is a judge
and so if you posit the highest ideal
then you put yourself in a position
where you're judged and that's when your
conscience
tortures you yeah and so you can
discover your ideal that way by having a
dialogue with your conscience and say
well i'm not
living up to who i should be well who
should that be like where where does
that figure come from
that's a great mystery that it's it's
it's your higher
it's the higher form of being that
you're capable of manifesting that's
calling to you
and let me say this it was a version of
when my father mortal father died
i write about this about being less
impressed and more involved
i sobered up i mean it was time to
become a man it was time to quit relying
on the fact that i knew he had my back
he was above government above law if i
really got a pickle
now he's visiting so this was i'm going
to discard my
spiritual father
we're racing to the red light buddy
that's all it is so what are you doing
what's here
there's one play and you go until you
die and that's it so what are you going
to do
don't be giving yourself let yourself
off the hook thinking well there may be
life after this
stop it so that's what i've been i've
gone through
that my feeling come out of that and
was and i didn't feel this till later
because i allowed myself to stay in the
midst of being really scared of oh my
gosh it was am i going to get struck by
lightning here
was that my god was going
thank you yes
wish more of us would put our hands on
the wheel or we take we throw this faith
card out there
really lacks basically like oh inshallah
says la vie i believe well you know
okay that's it then ride around and run
all the red lights get your damn hands
on the wheel yes you are
supposed to be self-determined so that
got me and
woke me up and sobered me up into that
position
now the going into the rust and coal
i'll say this
so i found that in my
it's i caught like almost like a
boomerang reverb wherever i am
strongest in my own life i find a i like
to go to the
i actually can inhabit the opposite even
better the deeper i go into whatever
would be to create the opposition
meaning when i played prosecuting
attorneys
i actually usually believe in the
defense's
position more and study their defense
more their position more
which then makes me again feel like an
underdog over here to go well i
really gotta know what my argument is
because i actually kind of agree with
them
when i play defense attorneys i'll
usually
agree or push myself to a point of
agreeing with the prosecution
well at a time where my faith was the
most fulfilled
rust and coal was like ah here's another
great
here's another what i call a boomerang
reverb here's another time to go
way over to the opposite side because
i'm so coming out here with so much
steam and where i am and what i really
believe and how i'm feeling in life
you got newborn children and all the
things that were opposition
that i have in my life opposition to
what russian rust and cult was
that was i i don't know why that is um
but i've all i look back and i have
a consistency of of that of wherever i
am in my life sometimes i'll lay in and
go play a character that i'm calling but
i'm also feeling like i'm drawing
something well now that you're so secure
here
let's test it let's go all the way to
the other side
because over there be geared up because
i feel so strong in the position say at
that time with my faith
now i have the strength to go inhabit
somebody over there
that is on the opposite side
and and not have to keep my eyes open to
make sure the door's open i can trust
that the door can be shut
and i'll still be there when i'm at it
when i'm when i'm done with this i'm
still there it's still happening
you have to see it because i don't want
to see it if i'm if i'm peeking over
there going hey are we okay
god are we okay with what i'm saying and
doing it no not without half-assing it
now i'm not really inhabiting the part
i'm playing rust and cold going i
believe
everything he says i'm i actually
thought rust and cold was hilarious
which you probably would now understand
by i've laughed at two comments
that from from things that you said
about the other people that spoke
like rust and coal yeah well things can
be things can be dark enough so that the
immediate response to them
can be laughter yeah
so i i um that that may have that
may help explain what you're asking but
i don't know why that is
i don't know why that is for me it's not
a straightforward thing to
to sort out um let me
ask you about a little bit more about
fame
so you know now and then you see stories
true or not about hollywood celebrities
who are
irritated with the consequences of their
fame
and it's very easy to be judgmental
about that
because they're obviously
the benefits to that fame appear obvious
monetary gain um access
access to opportunity um
the benefits i suppose of the ego
benefits perhaps of being known rather
than unknown
and then especially in the hollywood
community i would say
it's more difficult to generate sympathy
for
celebrities who are hurt by their fame
because
the price it's so obvious that that's
the price that has to be paid
to be successful in something that's
mass marketed like a movie
where your face is associated with the
product right you can't extract out
the success you can't distinguish
between the success and the fame
but but
i don't think it's possible to
understand what fame does
to your life until it's happened to you
so i'm curious like and you protect
yourself you hide
i don't mean in a withdrawing sort of
way but i mean you live in texas you
don't live in l.a
and you go on these sojourns where no
one knows you so
you you set up escape
mechanisms let's say or yes so what
tell me about fame and and about the
impact that it's had on you
so initially fame and fame happened to
me
extremely quickly it happened over one
weekend when the film and time to kill
came out
um the friday
afternoon before time kill opened that
friday night
um i'm walking down a promenade in santa
monica to go get my tunas fish sandwich
that i always like to get
400 people on the promenade 396 mind
their own business four of them looking
staring at me
a couple girls thought i was cute
somebody like my shoes
100 scripts out there that i want to do
i'll do any of those
99 knows one yes
now within 48 hours time to kill open up
that weekend very
very good good reviews et cetera et
cetera that monday
following monday 48 hours later i got
down the same promenade everything
inverted
now 396 out of the 400 people were
staring at me
and four weren't and i
knows check comply what have you now
those 90 those 100 scripts that were 99
knows of one yes
inverted 99 yes please do this
whoa the roof has been taken off
oh my god you're so good i love you oh
my god i'm so sorry about miss hud
number one who are you how did you know
i had a dog how did you know her name
was miss hud how
did you know she had cancer whoa you
just skipped four things
nobody's a stranger anymore everyone
seems to have an
inherent biography of me i'm feeling
trespassed on it is it okay
does that i love you mean something boy
they say that a lot out here i've only
said that to four people in my life
you shouldn't throw that word around
here a lot maybe that's how it's
supposed to be
yeah jesus did uh oh yeah so
trying to take that in um i learned a
great lesson after year seven
of fame and it's probably
year seven for a reason how old were you
when that when that happened
96 um 1888
eight years later 26 years old
26 so you're still pretty young but you
weren't 17.
so you had some maturity you had some
maturity at that point
thank you yeah i know more of what i
know more of what i'm not
than maybe more than what i do or what i
am
but i'm i'm i'm i'm aware enough of
who i don't want to be and i'm aware
enough that
i don't want to that i need some
discernation
in this now optionless yeses
that are coming at me my world i'm i'm
aware that i'm not that i need to again
be less impressed and more involved and
go hey i'm now that i have the chance
now that i've got the wheel
and i can go wherever i want where am i
gonna go
um which was the first unbalancing sort
of very
scary proposition which is why i took
off the first couple of times to the
monastery and then to christ in the
desert hear my damn self think
um trying to decipher and disseminate
what matters from what who am i in this
what i actually want to do
um what i not want to do what i want to
make stands on look i remember for a
while there
i had such a
my life was so many like things on top
the frequency of events from top of me
from peop just walking walking down the
street to interviews to talking to
somebody
my life was being recorded the world was
now a mirror and i remember telling my
feeling almost numb i couldn't put a
demarcation between
the life the fame i just gotten and
myself so i remember telling myself
well since you're kind of numb
just i took the old abraham lincoln
thing i was like just be a gentleman
and don't lie all right just stick to
these two things and i gave some boring
ass interviews
but i was a gentleman and i didn't lie
but i just said like don't even try and
get colorful don't even try and have an
opinion on anything
just just right now ride through this
and be a gentleman and don't lie and i
gave the same interview 50 times in a
row over
for about a few months yeah well there
is something to be said
um when you're exposed to that degree to
adopting a strategy of
don't do anything stupid for a while
yes it was so i was it was you know
surviving on the way to what could
possibly become thriving but it was
holding my head above water and going
just keep knocking them down you'll take
some time off you'll get some time off
to
let your memory catch up with you later
so to begin with it was a
shock and you've you developed some
strategies for dealing with it
what about over the longer run now it's
been you've been you've been well known
for
it's got to be 25 years say
so 32 or 33 years old i wake up and it
clicks for me one time
[Music]
that oh you got to get the joke in
hollywood
and the joke is it ain't personal it's
business right
and that's not a particular joke to
hollywood maybe it's a particular joke
in
in in life a lot uh
but that made me go ah okay
don't take it so personally when that
person i talked about earlier won't even
call you won't even call your
call you back because your last couple
of movies have failed and you spent
you know you were on the list to be
their children's godfather five years
ago
don't take that personally or don't take
it personally when that person
now because you did get hit is calling
you and wants to go out and hang out
again don't even bring up that hey
you wouldn't even answer back don't even
don't even tell them you understand the
score about how they
wouldn't call you then but now they do
now well that's a good that's a good
technique to avoid resentment
yes and resentment is so toxic it's so
toxic well that's what the that's what
getting the joke of the understanding
that wasn't personal
yeah yeah i've done that with people who
are looking for work
you know because it's difficult to find
a new job
um and you're going to get turned down a
lot in all likelihood you're going to
send your resumes out to 50 places and
get one positive reply if you're you
know you can expect that it might not be
that bad but it could be
it's not personal most of those jobs
don't even exist it hasn't
it doesn't it has something to do with
you but not that much
there's a huge situational factor there
and you have to take that into account
yes well it's similar to we lose
a loved one for me i lose my father well
after he dies
after he moves on from this life i find
out some facts where
the message and the messenger were not
sympatico
you know what he was teaching me and
what he was actually doing
there was a gap between those things and
i was like what
inevitably right inevitably you actually
want that from your father
you want your father to teach you better
than he is
yay you know yay but the first feeling
can be and i've seen people
yeah a lot of resentment oh yeah
betrayal yeah and there is it's true it
is
it is a betrayal but
but what you want your father to put
forward the worst version of himself and
use that as what he teaches you
see this goes back to that nihilistic
view if it's off or nothing then come on
let's make it all for everything
i'm i'm i'm with you on that so my
father moving on i
it happened pretty quickly for me of
going like oh i get it he's wanting me
to be better than
he is he's want me to do better i get it
bravo so
but i could tell maybe if that happened
two years earlier i wouldn't have been
in the emotional space
i might have been because it was
flabbergasting it's like meeting a hero
and they turn out to be an [ __ ] and
you're like well they're and they're
very likely to turn out badly in
comparison to your idealization of them
100 which and but but at the same time
you go talk to your favorite musician
you followed who you performed with your
version of patriotism and fairness in
the world and you go meet them they turn
out to be an [ __ ] and
you go like they don't even believe in
what they wrote you're like what
but you and well if flawed people were
incapable of creativity we wouldn't have
any creativity
right you know and so i think what you
have to do when you're dealing with
creative people is realize that
or people who are creative and
accomplished even is realize that
the fact that they've managed that
despite all their flaws is the thing
that's truly remarkable because they
have as many flaws as the next person
yep so so thank god there this is why
you know when i see someone like louis
ck for example
hillary terribly i think well
yeah he did some things that were
unseemly
certainly even by his own standards
obviously
um so what do we make of that well
there's plenty of people who do unseemly
things but
not but very few of them are as
masterful a comedian as louis c.k so do
we want to lose him because he's flawed
right seems it seems inappropriate
because
we'd lose everybody that way and then we
just have loss
that's not helpful yes
yes i mean i think you're leaning into
you know
a lot of what we call a cancel culture
today yeah is can that uh
you know in the name
of rehabilitation does it do we have to
have a world in which
we are able to grow and evolve
if that's what we're trying to do now
oh i mean you know i'm not for repeat
offenders or
or tyrants but if someone screws up and
they have sincere
they sincerely want retribution
i think it's fair to give these people
well it better be because otherwise
we're all doomed
right well absolutely like there's not a
person among us who hasn't made repeated
errors and
and if if contrition and and repentance
aren't sufficient then
we're all damned no doubt about that
so all right so so we were
we were continuing our discussion on
fame so you
you you're 25 years into being famous
and
you seem to be doing handling
your success right
in in a manner that allows you to be
pleased about the way your life has
unfolded and
so thank god for that and here you are
you're still here after all these years
and so you've handled your fame well how
come how could you manage that
okay how can a man is that well big
big thing for me and that worked for me
in my life like this just getting a
click
of a word or an understanding will
completely change my perspective when i
go ah that's it that's true
i'm not quite banging my head against
the proverbial wall oh now i understand
that one big click for me
seven years was it ain't personal it's
business that helped a lot
from but okay i understand the
impermanence of this just roll dance
dance with this guy dance with it
next one that was just sort of a
behavioral perspective
even though it sounds like a cool
one-liner was
when people would ask or i would of
myself
run into an inconvenience of fame a
paparazzi or whatever
someone looking over the wall might be
able to go outside
i was like i'm not going to cry about it
because that check is already cached
right that's right
i can't go back if it's inevitable i'm
gonna figure out a good
way to get it through this i then
started to say okay well when you're
watched in life matthew and a camera's
on you notice how you speed up
and you get a little nervous well why
don't you look at this like a good
of the master acting class see if you
can go out into the world with eyes on
you
uninvited eyes cameras recording and
actually behave
and do just the behavior that you went
out to do
yeah you know okay we're in new york
city
makeup artist doing my face my son's
three years old
he's talking to his favorite things fire
trucks she goes with my husband
fired captain he's actually blocks away
going free and bring the fire truck over
downtown new york well that means a lot
of paparazzi are going to come right but
my three-year-old son doesn't know what
paparazzi are
and he gets to see his first fire truck
live
do i go down there and show my son's
first fire truck or do i tell him no
son i'm not gonna see the fire truck
because you'll understand it later there
are people with cameras
i'm like f that man my son wanted to see
his first fire truck is much more
important and came before any right that
anyone's got that
inconvenience that comes with my fame
we're going to see the damn fire truck
well we go see the fire truck he sees
the fire truck cameras all around
he didn't understand what it was i'm
sitting there going like this was about
let my son see the fire truck
i'm trying to live my life and i and i
check with myself
i don't i'm not foolish with my fame i
don't open the doors
and invite the the the devils in or open
my
you know self up and say yeah look have
a look come on and now i
understand i can be fully taken
advantage of and there are plenty of
people who would love to take advantage
of that
but i often tell myself again who's
wagging who
what are your rights mcconaughey as a
human
as a citizen as the man you are
don't let those be taken away from you
because of something you got
along the way which was fame and
inconveniences that come with that
so while i don't advertise my wife and i
say this we do not advertise ourselves
but if we want to go for a walk
in the park or go see that proverbial
fire truck and show our child that
we're going to go let's do it and we're
doing it if you want to record us i call
them the discovery channel
record it you know what good use of film
good use
recording so there is advantages to
having eyes on youtube because
it does force you to behave you can
leave your keys in your car in a lot of
places because if you
come come rob your car they're going to
document the one kind of robber
it's a bit of a security blanket on that
too
um so you see where i've spun a few
things here and perspective
not denying inconvenience but saying hey
if this this check is cash
here's how i'm going to try and get
constructive and do it and so
fame now um it gets
me in certain doors i've had to watch
this
um things that i'll say
a famous person can come out in bold
print
not just on the printed page but two
people
so i've i've had i've told you too
strongly
and actually hurt people with my words
where maybe i didn't have the emoji to
put on the end of
the the what i wrote with the wink and
they heard it
like i was throwing a dagger at him but
i was going no no i didn't i was just
tickling you i didn't mean to hurt you
you know and what tickled me may bruise
somebody else and my words come out with
that weight sometimes so i have to watch
that
definitely i remember when i was a
teenager i got
put down by someone who was
reasonably well known in public and
it was a misunderstanding but it burned
itself into my memory and i thought if
i'm ever in a situation
where i'm well known i'm going to
remember this so that i don't and
like had it been a normal had he been
an everyday person let's say
what he said wouldn't have had nearly
the impact on me that it did
so and that is a strange thing to have
to realize and to weigh your words that
way
um i'm cognizant of your time i know
that you have another obligation coming
up and
so i thought it might be useful
to move towards closing this i i
people are going to wonder how it was
that we came to have a conversation
yes and so maybe you could shed some
light on that
and it's because i'm curious i'm curious
about it as well
i got turned on to you from a friend of
mine about
four years ago i think three years ago
and i started listening to a lot
what you were saying and
many of the things you you said i had
been thinking about but i heard you
putting them into words and context i
was like what that's that's
that's what i'm talking about that's
what i'm trying to get to i found
um uh and a lot of goes back to talk
about
self-determination which we've talked
about a lot about your self-authoring
and then you hear
you hear you see a lot of those threads
through my book maybe in a different way
in a more folksy way
but a lot of what you've said
gave me confidence to go
i i'm going to put my story on paper
um so i thank you for that and that's
why i thank you for the back of the in
the back of the book
you know i reached out um to you
uh i guess a year and a half ago or so
and you and i chatted and i've
stayed in contact with you with your
daughter um
you know your definition one of the
great simple things i said earlier
sometimes just to re-unders
understanding a word differently i've
always
had trouble
in about a tough relationship an awkward
relationship with with
many words but my late my two that i've
had the longest trouble with are
vulnerability and humility
yeah these are tough ones they're tough
ones so
humility i you know okay be humble well
for
for you decades be humble
i lost confidence when i was humble i i
i
feigned false modesty which i felt which
i knew at the time that's arrogant what
are you doing
right absolutely it's very difficult
to be to have humility without being
arrogant about it
weirdly enough you said and correct me
if i if i misquote you
it's humility is known and you have more
to learn
you're either in love with what you know
or you're in love with what you don't
know and there's a lot more of what you
don't know
so pick your love carefully oh
well that i went oh i purchased
i'm in on that but for the first time
when i see that
i'm not shrinking i'm actually standing
taller
my heart's higher my chin's higher my
shoulders are further back
right right i have more courage going
forward because oh 100
i i can rely on that until i'm gone and
maybe even further than that
yes i have more to learn i purchase but
now i can go
forward with confidence of watching what
i do know what i have built
i can add more courage i can forgive
easier
i can i can i can take responsibility
with more courage
um i can take care of the things i've
built and
to attend those gardens better with with
that understanding of humility so
for that i thank you i appreciate that
yeah it's a humility
i i i i want to throw a little funsy out
there for you
okay so while i was writing
and i've i've become a fan which
i'd love to continue talking with you
more about this subject divine
objective we in the third eye sort of
the jumbotron
of our life we hop out of ourselves and
have a look or we project forward in our
lives
and say who am i in 10 years or what
would my eulogy be
you see i write a lot about these things
in in
the book but while i was writing
i hopped out i gave myself the pleasure
one night
after a a few sips and it was late at
night
and mind you the most trouble i was i'm
happy to say this the hardest thing
about going to write this book for me
was making myself go to bed i was
putting 17 hours a day
17 hour days and i was like you've got
to get some sleep but anyway one of
these nights when i was in the fever
pitch on fire writing
i wrote down some i hopped outside of
myself and said i'm going to write
reviews
from people that i think this is what
they would say about this book
after reading and
this is one of them that's a great way
to become aware of your audience or of
the audience you want to have
well you have to speak to an audience
when you're writing obviously
well it's you know it's it's a very
subjective experience but i think
there's there is another as you said but
the
good thing about talking to oneself in
the third person
is it's a different view of awareness
it's an objective
awareness back at like oh am i actually
doing what i intended to do
is what i intended actually being
recorded is what being
recorded actually what's being received
there could be a lot of gaps in between
those things and i'm trying
with those gaps right so
um i hopped outside of myself and
wrote a uh um a
wrote a uh um which what i thought you
would say about green lights
and max mcconaughey the author
it's entrance level understanding to
master class psychology
delivered in a folk song i mean the
guy's got the gift of gab man
what can i say jordan peterson
that's quite remarkable because that is
very close to what i thought
you know i so i think you nailed it um
you did it
it's very difficult to put forward a
message
without being propagandistic and the
best way to do that is to tell stories
and your book is full of stories and and
the stories seem to me to add up to a
life well lived and that's a good model
and so it's a model but it's also not
put forth as a model so it doesn't
suffer from the flaws of
the flaws that might come along without
putting forth you know it's and i guess
that's because you stayed contemplative
i mean one of the things i've tried to
do in my lectures is to remember that
i'm lecturing to me
as well you know i'm part of the
audience if i'm talking about how
we might behave i mean we i don't yet
think that i'm outside of the problems
that i'm discussing
those two are not a contradiction more
of us can understand that we're talking
to ourselves
as well yes well it takes the sting out
of things and it keeps you on the ground
so well i think that's quite funny that
you wrote that review and it's also
quite funny that it is in line with
with what i thought i read the book i
should show the book again since this is
a good time to do that
and and you know that's the cover of
with my picture on it but underneath
that
is is the really cool thing that sort of
is the is this symbol that's the
metaphor that i'm playing with which is
all the red and yellow lights that we
have in our life the hardships the
crisis is
in the rear view mirror of life at least
via lessons learned
we will reveal green light assets that
we needed
um it's not denying the crisis you know
of
even the death of a loved one but it is
saying oh there were lessons even in
that and i would offer i wondered you
know
jordan if some of these lessons we know
we're going to learn them when we're in
the crisis some we don't know till next
month some are probably not going to
know to our death bed
and i would argue that some will never
be realized until maybe our great
great great grandkids realize them three
generations from now
and there's a green light in this year
we're in right now
big green lights in this big red light
year of cobit and social unrest and
and and political distrust and and and
people having to redefine who they are
and what politics is and what's fairness
and what's equality and
all the this in the extremes everyone
there's a big there's
big green lights that will be revealed
out of this year
don't know when but
more than optimistic i think realistic
that that's going to be true
that's an excellent place to end
i would say thank you very much it's
it's been a pleasure talking to you and
i
deeply appreciated the acknowledgement
and i'm very
pleased that my work has
contributed to what you've produced i
also
get a kick out of the fact that our
books are chasing each other on the
top 10 list on amazon so i think that's
quite
well it's a privilege and it's an
impossible privilege and so i'm very
pleased to see that and i wish you the
best of luck i hope that we
get a chance to talk again i enjoyed
that very much
i did too good good and hopefully
the audience will respond in the same
way i think so
so thanks for taking the time me
my pleasure jordan i very much
appreciate i look forward to the next
time
um good to see you sir good to see you
too
ciao
[Music]
you